y
[Música]
el 11 de septiembre estaba en bosnia
viendo las noticias en el cuartel
general de la brigada norte allí
esperaba regresar a sarajevo después de
unos días en ese contingente
yo era un general de una estrella en ese
entonces y el asistente en jefe del
equipo para las operaciones de
estabilidad de la otan
y
de hecho lo que poco se sabe es que la
primera operación antiterrorista después
del 9/11 no fue en afganistán sino una
operación en sarajevo
había ciertos individuos que estaban
viajando de pakistán pasando por
sarajevo y tus la y luego desaparecían
en las zonas sin gays y había varias
ongs que además de ayudar a los
ciudadanos necesitados en bosnia
herzegovina también ayudaban a facilitar
el viaje de estos individuos en la zona
schengen
así que la primera operación tuvo lugar
poco después del 9/11 y hubo más
despistes de ésta
[Música]
primero que todo eso de que el ejército
iraquí acababa de colapsar no es
correcto en realidad hubo varios fuertes
combates y operaciones de alto riesgo
que fueron conducidas en esa época y que
hubieran podido ser más peligrosas y
dañinas
[Música]
y al final establecimos un lugar de
operaciones bastante amplio al suroeste
de najaf
esa es la ciudad más sagrada para los
chiítas es allí donde está ubicada la
mezquita dorada y una ciudad con una
población de unas 600.000 personas más o
menos
y decidimos que era esa la primera
ciudad que debíamos liberar
desde muy temprano empecé a darme cuenta
que lo que creíamos acerca de irak
estaba siendo reputado poco a poco y eso
es lo que me llevó a decirle al
periodista que estaba en bebé estas
palabras que se volvieron famosas
cuéntame cómo termina esto
porque esto no iba a terminar como nos
dijeron que ocurría cuando estábamos en
kuwait
en otras palabras que entraríamos y el
ejército iraquí se rendiría o se pondría
de nuestro lado
sadam y sus secuaces se irían pero que
el resto de iraquíes se quedaría
traes un montón de líderes ellos aceptan
un nuevo gobierno
mirad se restablece y nos vamos para la
casa con desfile de victoria era claro
que eso no iba a suceder y nos dimos
cuenta de eso en najaf luego en kárbala
luego en quilla y por supuesto después
en bagdad donde no había fuerza policial
no había ejército ni fuerzas de
seguridad no habían autoridades
gubernamentales
nos pertenecía
como dijo el secretario de estado colin
powell así como ocurre en cerámica si lo
rompe de suyo
nosotros lo habíamos roto y nos
pertenecía las autoridades iraquíes y
los miembros del gobierno iban a
establecer un nuevo gobierno al que
prometimos ayudar y luego irnos pero eso
no iba a suceder
y el nivel de violencia en bagdag era
horrendo en diciembre de 2006 se
hallaron 53 cuerpos de civiles muertos
por la violencia en sólo 24 horas
eso era en la capital de irak la
situación en materia de seguridad estaba
fuera de control me habían dicho que
debía regresar a irak en el verano de
2007 todo eso mientras oigo rumores que
quizás debía regresar antes de esa fecha
y empecé a recibir llamadas de gente en
washington incluso de la casa blanca
me preguntaron de hecho hacia diciembre
de 2006 si ustedes fuera nombrado
comandante en irak que necesitaría y yo
dije todo lo que haya mal en otras
palabras todas las fuerzas disponibles
en los eeuu
por supuesto el presidente tomó esa
famosa decisión de llevar a cabo ese
surge que implicaba cerca de 25.000
militares estadounidenses más y portas
más de los países de la coalición
pero lo que más tuvo importancia lo que
hizo que el sur que fuera exitoso no fue
un mayor número de efectivos sino de
ideas
así es como cambiamos nuestra estrategia
y nuestras tácticas en el terreno
y eso era una diferencia de 180 grados
de lo que se venía haciendo antes de
todo eso
durante 18 meses que duró ese surge
redujimos la violencia en un 85%
es por supuesto un hecho que fue el
presidente bush quien tomó la decisión
de invadir irak y de eliminar las armas
de destrucción masiva algo en lo que se
creía fuertemente en esa época aunque
más adelante se haya podido demostrar
que no era cierto
dicho esto no creo que se le pueda
culpar por todos los desafíos que
surgieron desde entonces en el oriente
medio y el gran medio oriente desde
entonces
[Música]
claramente la primavera árabe como fue
descrita fue la fuente de la sublevación
en túnez con la expulsión del líder zine
al abidine benalí en egipto el
presidente mubarak
en libia gadafi en siria en realidad eso
fue un catalizador de la revuelta contra
bachar al asad y lo mismo en yemen
spring los hechos de la primavera árabe
más allá de lo que describí son
independientes de lo que ocurrió en irak
de nuevo creo que es muy injusto culpar
al presidente buscó todo lo que salió
mal en el medio oriente las últimas
décadas
james
bueno reconociendo claramente que fue
uno de los que tomó la decisión de
llevar a cabo la invasión a irak
algo que no salió como esperábamos y que
de cierta forma claramente dio pie a que
irán aprovechar a esto